the the three-part
sequence of one line of these works by
uh amit
rachel and ayush and amit will will
start over
all right thanks can everyone see the
screen and hear me
and and again if some people join now
let me encourage
if you're a participant not a panelist
you want to participate you want to ask
questions raise your zoom hand
and the good folks at simons will
promote you to a panelist
if you are already have the ability to
show your video uh if it's a
if it's at all comfortable for you i
will be grateful and i think the
speakers would also be grateful
for you to turn off the new camera so
they don't feel that they're just
talking to a bunch of icons
and then yes and and feel free to just
unmute yourself and ask questions during
the talk
i just want to confirm before i start
that uh everyone can
both hear me and see my slides can
someone please say something
about that yes okay great thank you
um all right so you know with that
excellent introduction from from yael
first before i say anything actually
about our work um
it is just so true what she said i think
this is really uh
all the stuff that we're going to be
talking about is a victory for the
community it was really a
incredible patient uh
community effort in which there were a
lot of
people who really did you know fight
through
quite um um
environment including a number of people
who were students when they were working
really really hard on this and therefore
actually had to deal with
what shafi was talking about which is um
uh
you know some resistance some
significant resistance to put it mildly
um
and uh and yes it's really a community
effort
and what i'm going to be talking about
today um in the first part of this
of this talk is just a
just an awesome two plus year uh
collaboration with hi ayu shane and
rachel lim who will also hear from
after after me uh about our result that
gets
uh i o from the final assumptions as
yeah already uh
already told you about so um
so let me sin since ayala has already uh
introduced everything
let me just jump straight into uh into
into it
and again please stop me please ask me
questions this is definitely the right
way to go and it's really fun to see
that
in this workshop so we will show that io
exists assuming sub-exponential hardness
of all the following assumptions
lpn over zp lwa pr using nc0 and the
sxv8 assumption i'm going to go over all
these
the main focus of my talk is to talk
about these assumptions
and then also talk about this key
pseudorandom object and sort of one
aspect of it
and we're going to hear more and more
about that as our sequence of talks
continues so um so again just sort of
pictorially
uh as the aisle alluded to
really the key um the key new thing
that we built in this new work
is a new pseudorandom object and i'm
going to talk about that and we're going
to you're going to
keep on learning more and more about
that and um
and we're basically on these four
assumptions and it'll really be the lpn
and prg then c0 assumption
that'll be critical for the building of
this museum random object
lwe and s6ph are mostly used in prior
works
that we build upon many many such
fireworks so
just with no further ado let me just
jump straight into
the sort of key assumption the
consumption that really made
uh this work possible that's why buzz
you know called our
scheme the ltn based team because the
lpn is sort of playing a key really key
role
so so what is this what is the lpn
over zp assumption uh this is
the learning parity with noise
assumption ltn assumption has a long
history within cryptography
dates back to the work of blum it all in
1993 he looked at it
in the case for p equals two and then uh
in a joint work with yuval and manoj
we uh looked at it in the case in the
general case for
for larger prime in cryptography however
the actual assumption goes back much
much further the the ideas and the
assumption behind it
goes further in information theory back
to the classic work of hamming
and work from the 1950s where the idea
of
linear codes and random linear codes
over large fields over
or general zp were introduced so again
back in the 50s all the stuff was being
discussed
so just to review the the most basic
aspect of this
suppose we have this matrix a and this
is a
tall and skinny matrix so it has
l columns so l is a smaller number and
it has
n rows and n is some polynomial in l
and to encode a vector s
which is also over z p to the l we just
multiply so we multiply by s and we get
the code word c so that's why we call it
a linear code
and again are you moving inside
sorry are you moving your slides uh it
should be
on the lpn over zp slot oh it's still on
the for me at least it's on the
introduction slide
no for me it's okay uh okay okay i guess
this is starting to happen do you want
me either no it's my thing my internet's
sort of flicked out in the middle it's
fine
okay it's talking to me before and the
living zoom and
rejoining uh helped help do that uh yes
it's
uh my internet
it just flicked out from it yeah okay
but if more people have that problem
then please tell me
maybe i should leave and rejoin so so we
can do whatever it takes to make this
work
um and yeah just maybe
uh yeah once in a while you you can
mention same words as as we see on this
slide so people understand ah very good
yes okay so as we see on the slide
we're talking about the alpha and or zp
assumption and we're talking about
random linear codes
and you know so we have on the slide
this matrix a
this vector s and just the
multiply a times s and you get a code
word c so again this is
classic ideas from error correcting
codes
many many many decades of taught have
gone into this
and in particular when we think about
random linear codes where this matrix a
is completely uniformly selected from z
b to the l
again this has a very long history and
all the way back in the 1950s and the
really groundbreaking
and incredibly influential work of
gilbert and varshanav
they showed that if you have a random
linear code
they actually have incredibly strong
combinatorial error correcting
capabilities
when it is dealt with but when it's
combined with sparse error
and now for the purpose of this result
and this talk let me be very concrete
about what type of sparks are we're
talking about
so as you can see on the slide um we
have this error vector e which is an
n-dimensional vector and this
error vector is zero
almost always but with probability
one over l to the delta where delta has
any constant greater than zero it's just
a random
field element in zp and otherwise it's
zero
so if you think about it what that means
is that we expect something like you
know
n over l to the delta elements of e
to be non-zero we're in random positions
but again the vast majority of the
positions will be
will be zero and in fact for even much
stronger much
much more dense errors it has long been
known again since the 1950s
that random linear codes are
capable of correcting such error
combinatorially
but not efficiently so again the fact
that we
knew that there was a combinatorial
artifacting capability there was an
information theoretic way of correcting
meant there was an incredible amount of
motivation to try to find a way to do
this efficiently
and yet in all those decades um there
has been no efficient decoding algorithm
that's been learned for random linear
codes and in fact by efficient here
i don't just mean polynomial time like
polynomial in n
and l but even sub exponential in l
there's been almost no progress and i'm
going to talk a little bit about that
in just a moment and then hopefully
you'll hear even more about it
later today from benny but
um because that because there hasn't
been any any progress
on these decoding algorithms uh there's
a natural assumption which is called the
lpn
over zp assumption which just says
that if i look at as plus e if i look at
these
random i look at a random
uh uh matrix a and
so a comma a s plus e and this you know
random code word
that is then perturbed by this sparse
error the sparse random error then in
fact this looks
uniform so it's a pseudorandomness
assumption of a comma a s plus e
looks random okay and
again just to be very clear for building
i o what precisely are we assuming
we are assuming that there exists
arbitrary
small constant absol s constants epsilon
and delta greater than zero
such that this assumption a comma a s
plus c is going to
from uniform where the error probability
is
1 over alpha delta that holds against
all time 2 to the l to the epsilon
adversary
that is the precise assumption that
we're making that's what we call the lpn
over cp assumption
and in fact this assumption
also follows uh from a heart from the
hardness of decoding so from the actual
problem that has been worked on for all
these decades
unsuccessfully there is a
classic and quite natural source of
decision reduction due to
apple bomb at all that shows
that uh this assumption this
indistinguishability assumption
pseudorandom's assumption is true if it
is sub-exponentially hard to recover
s from a comma a s plus c so if it's
actually hard to decode s
then in fact it's hard to distinguish a
comma s plus c
from from uniform and i just want to
briefly mention a few more details for
those of you who want to know all the
details
um in order to invoke this uh
this search to decision reduction in
order to only assume
the hardness of decoding we need to set
the prime p to be 2 to the l to the
epsilon prime for some tiny constant
epsilon prime less than epsilon
okay and the reason for that is that
this search decision reduction
the one that we know of course there
could be better ones and i think there
might be better ones
but the ones that we actually know um
also run in time polynomial
in the actual uh modulus p
so in order for us to invoke that source
of decision reduction
we do need to make sure that the prime
is small but that's not essential to our
work in any way
so if for example you don't feel
comfortable doing that and you only feel
comfortable assuming
the lpn assumption uh against
adversaries
uh uh where uh the
modulus is larger than the running time
of the adversary
that's fine too we can make that
assumption and everything will still be
fine in our in our construction
it says in that case we have to make the
decisional assumption the pseudo-around
this assumption directly
we can't uh go by the search decision
reduction as of right now
maybe there are better decision
reductions and that's very well
motivated by our work
but as of right now um kind of those are
the options
that you have but we can work for any
sub-exponential setting
of the prime p so i mean yes
is there any monotonicity known that say
if p
is larger or smaller are there any
reductions known in either directions
whether the problem
becomes harder or become easier when
yeah that's a great question and and
presumably we'll talk about this even
more
later on but as of right now as far as i
know
there's no such relationship known it is
true that there are attack algorithms
for lpn
that only seem to run that only seem to
run
um a little bit efficiently when p
is two uh maybe a very small prime i'm
not even sure about that latter part
so it does seem based on the algorithms
that we know the
algorithms that have been constructed
over the last several decades
that the larger p is the harder the
problem it becomes
but there's no proof of that there's no
understanding of that and i think this
is
extremely well motivated as a question
for us to think about but i am not aware
of any such uh
relationship yeah in some sense you
could actually think that larger p
gives you in some sense more bits of
information so
like roughly speaking you could think
that if
log p is k then it's as if you get a k
factor of extra equations uh
but uh i don't know usually getting k
factor of x
wouldn't matter much so maybe that
doesn't really make a difference
right yeah i mean that that log b
because
especially in our setting where where
log p is still like you know l to the
epsilon prime it's still very small
that's still a very small number of
definitions of them anyway giving you n
equals poly l equations
right so um that doesn't at least again
we don't know how to make use of that
information in any
in any way and neither has anyone been
able to figure that out yeah
i don't think there's any any region
even if you let the bit size of pv
triple exponentially in the other
parameters i don't think you know
anything better
in the contrary the bigger p only
hurts known attacks yep exactly exactly
as you've all said
and i'll try to talk about it but just
that we know this is the basis for all
the attacks kind of
they don't know how to exploit this
additional information right that's the
point
although information theoretically you
have many information
basically we we have no other ways
at least we don't know other ways except
for tweaking this this is simple
right as a as a unit a big
information
right i also want to just mention that
there is another intuitive way
in which it is actually a little bit
harder which is the the eis are
more random right like the eis when
there is an error
then its uniform over the entire large
field right so it's not just a bit flip
but um yeah the ratio between yeah
yeah right so in that sense also there's
some intuition as to why it should be
harder but but it's just intuition we
don't have good idea and maybe i'll
mention one other little thing
which is that you know as i'll point out
again in my slides but
as is obvious to everyone who's looking
at this assumption on the slide
this looks very much like lwe right the
only difference
is that this e is sparse as opposed to
being small in lw
right now but the fact that he is
small in lwe does let you do these like
modulus switching right it lets you kind
of argue about
elderly with regard to one modulus
versus algae back to another modulus
because you can just um uh you know
divide and then round
and that's still a valid error but you
can't do that in the context of
alternatives we don't know how to do
that in the conflict of lpn
because when you do that modulus
reduction you'll introduce errors almost
everywhere and we
crucially need e to be sparse when we're
reducing lpn
to you know lpnp versus lpn p prime
right we want to maintain the sparsity
so that's sort of the technical
difficulty that um
that we have in terms of being able to
explore how the different values of
prime relate to one another
so a question to those who study these
lpn
or lw translations if you have a fixed
entropy budget and you have to
distribute it
right so you have you encode you take a
random code word in a linear code and
you have to use your entropy budget um
so obviously it's a big question to
relate
to lwa but we have more stocks against
lw than we have against lpn
do we know that lpn is in some sense uh
investor do we have a candidate uh way
to distribute entropy that is better
with respect to known attacks in lpn
so if you have a fixed entropy budget
you'll be doing some hybrid within
an lwe has anything like this being
considered
these are really all just instances of a
more general assumption right which is
just
the hardness of noisy linear decoding
right and
um that's a great question you know what
is the best
distribution over e with an entropy
budget in terms of hardness
i don't know the answer to that question
and um um
yeah i i can quote to the leader who
claimed that the garcia knows this
should be the best one but uh
i don't think the lpn should be the best
sorry ben i couldn't
no no benny what did you say
i said it i mean i had this discussion
once with
the claim that the galaxy i know it
should be better than the
like given a budget then maybe maybe
it's a budget maybe it's id
noise or something maybe it's in the
same yeah
is better harder
but but i don't think that we have a
formal way to to to show anything like
it and it's not even clear what the
evidence
that we have uh you could you can look
at the best attacks but
so in terms of best attacks the best
known attack on this assumption
is again very far from what we're
assuming
so the best known attack is something
like two to the order of
l to the one minus delta and remember
delta is just an arbitrarily small
constant like zero point zero one
so the delta to that is something like
zero to the sorry two to the l to the
point nine nine
right and we're only assuming two to the
l to the zero point zero one uh hardens
so just
just in terms of where we are with
regard to attacks there's a vast
gulf despite all these decades of work
but hopefully they'll be like a renewed
interest a renewed push
by all those great algebraic crypto
analysts out there and we definitely
want that we want everything to be
looked at super closely so let's all try
to attack it and get
better ideas about um how to attack lpn
and how to
relate lp and other uh assumptions as
well
so who knows maybe coding series will
give us the breakthrough right
yeah maybe although again they the
codingers are the one we've been working
on the longest
they've been working on it for decades
and decades and decades
in some sense we're the new the
stragglers you know we're the new people
on the block as cryptographers um and
in fact just uh this is a slide that's
just
shamelessly stolen from jaffwa who's
looked into this question
uh much more systematically than i have
and uh this is just a just a small
sample
um according to him of uh papers in the
um in the literature that have tried to
attack lpn in various ways
and so i mean just to make the point
over large p
over real numbers it's an easy problem
excellent point yes
yes that's a great point right that if
we want to look at this over the reels
and of course
something we've seen in crypto over and
over and over again and especially in
the context of i o
right sum of squares and even simpler
algorithms from these settings
can in fact uh efficiently decode uh
over the reels you can do l1
minimization you can use like classic
optimization
techniques to um to decode efficiently
if we're seeing this over the wheels so
that's something we've seen over and
over and over
again in cryptography that when you
introduce the mod p structure
everything changes for example
multiplication right i mean they're just
they're just lots and lots of
problems that we know are hard um
or expensive like all these things like
exponentiation might be
you know we've thought is hard for
decades whereas exponentiate expectation
over the reals is
is trivial to invert we've known how to
do that without more than a thousand
years
right with a logarithm computation so
this is definitely one of those examples
of
a case where things are easier over the
wheels
and hard over apparently hard over
finite fields
um and i'll just make one uh
note here which is that in fact over
p equals two so for the case where you
have um
uh uh we're working over z2
and for the case of significantly more
dense errors of constant rate error
um there was a really a breakthrough
work uh
back in 2003 by uh by blum kalai and
wasserman really a celebrated result
where they were able to improve from an
exponential attack
to something like 2 to the n over log n
so it's still
super far from it from an attack on our
or on our assumption
but it was able to sort of shave a log
factor off of the
uh of the exponent and in fact as far as
i know
for our setting for both and really for
two reasons both because
we're looking at a large prime a large
modulus
but also because we're looking at the
sparser error scenario we don't know how
to even
adapt the blam kalai wasserman algorithm
to even save that
log factor off of the uh off of the
exponent so i don't even know how to do
two to the l to the one that's not the
whole thing divided by log out like even
that's not something that we know how to
do
so they're really great questions to
think about here there's been a lot of
work
especially in the coding theory
community but um
but still we know almost nothing so
um so that's a little brief introduction
to lp university and again we're going
to hear more about this from from benny
uh i think right later today um
and just on the slide i'm just pointing
out that um
you know this is this was in pictures
and just to write it mathematically
you know if we have these um row vectors
of our random matrix a if we call them
the a
i's then we're assuming that if i give
to you
you the adversary a i comma a i dot
s plus e i then this is computationally
indistinguishable
from a i comma u i where each ui is just
chosen uniformly at random
c that is the uh the assumption we're
making
okay so so me just out of curiosity
uh just for my knowledge all these like
50 papers you put on the previous slide
uh basically you're saying they they're
like survey papers they don't have any
results because you said
basically the trivial algorithm so what
does it do
what are they doing yeah so the point is
that there are things you can do to
shape
like some small constant factor you know
so like a lot of these algorithms are
like oh we can shave a factor like
instead of
two to the like in our language would be
instead of two to the l to the one minus
delta we can do
two to the point seven times l to the
one minus delta
you know so there are none it's not like
there hasn't been any work there's been
lots of interesting little sorry i
shouldn't say little
there have been lots of interesting
algorithmic ideas
um that have you know uh tried to
to improve the efficiency and again it's
such an important problem for
information theorists
that there really is just too much work
on this like there's really an
extensive literature here but it's all
trying to you know shave small factors
shave as much as you can get um so
that's what
my understanding of these papers are i
have not read these papers again i stole
the slide from jeffwa
but that is my understanding having
looked at a
very very tiny subset of these papers
okay any other questions before we move
on
so actually before i talk about the
other
assumptions i actually want to tell you
right away
immediately how we are going to use this
actual
assumption okay so the thing in the blue
box
that actual assumption like this actual
indistinguishability property
is only going to arise in our entire
line of work
in exactly one way and it's an extremely
simple way
so i want to just tell you about that
right away ah sorry sorry okay
i forgot to mention one more one more
thing about elphian before i move on
um so i want to remind you that we're
only assuming lpn
for an arbitrarily small constant delta
greater than zero
okay so that's for example delta equals
0.1
okay and while that is quite sparse
error
that is still too sparse in error
to be known to imply for example public
key encryption
the classic work of aleknovich which was
then extended by apple bomb at all
to achieve public key encryption
needs delta to be greater than or equal
to one half sorry that should be greater
than or equal to
one half so uh
so in fact uh the version of the
assumption that we're making
is uh is even more plausible in the
sense that we're assuming
that lpn holds with actually much more
error
than was needed to be assumed to imply
public encryption and again even the
public
encryption version has not been attacked
successfully in any non-trivial way
as i already pointed out um and so
kind of intriguingly although i'm not
betting my life on it in any
in any sense i wouldn't even bet dollars
on it but
as of right now again we do not know how
to build public key encryption
from uh lpn with delta greater than zero
or any sort of public key
you know crypto mania type of type of
object
so in fact this might be a mini crypt
assumption right it could very well be
that um lpn with delta greater than zero
is really the kind of a
mini as far as we know right now it is a
minicrypt assumption
and that again distinguishes it from lwe
or in our context also sxth so we're
making
two other assumptions which are
definitely cryptomania assumptions
lwe and sxth
but as far as we can tell this
this sort of mild variant of lpn that
we're making
assumption we're making um because it
has
sufficiently dense error
is just a midi grip assumption all right
um
so with that uh let me tell you how
we're going to use this function because
how are we actually going to use
um and indeed we're going to use it to
build
this new ceramic object so let me talk
to you about that
so at the heart of our work the heart of
this new work
is a key pseudonym object that we call a
structured seed prg
and what makes it different from normal
prgs
are a few things but sort of
structurally what makes it different
is that the seed has two parts
it has a public seed and a secret seed
and of course as the name suggests the
public seed
is included in the output of the of the
sprg so it's revealed to everyone
and it's only the secret seed that is
actually kept hidden
from the adversary and this idea of
using both a public seed and a secret
seed
uh really originated in this this line
of work um
that uh sort of third generation line of
work that
that yael talked about um
as mentioned here okay and
in particular this notion of sprg that
we are introducing
has sort of three main requirements uh
which i've
written out here is one two and three
and i'm only talking about the
one of them and then we're going to hear
more about the other ones later
so the first requirement um as alluded
to by yael
and as working here on the slide is this
kind of degree to efficiency requirement
and again very roughly speaking what
that says is that the output
is a degree two polynomial in the secret
seed
it's allowed to be a higher degree
polynomial in the public seed but
when um when you look at that polynomial
and you restrict it only to
how it's depending on the secret seed
it's only degree two
okay and that's absolutely essential for
using bilinear maps
as yeah already told you about
okay the second requirement is expansion
which is a which which is kind of more
normal for prgs it just says that the
length of the structured seed
should be m to the y minus epsilon this
is yet another constant epsilon
actually the sum of both the secret and
the public yes
yes yes both the public seed and the
secret seed the length of that should be
m to the one minus epsilon
um if the sprg outputs m bits so again
it's doing some
polynomial expansion um on
uh the length of the structured c okay
and there's also a crs there's also like
a public parameters um
which is also allowed which can be long
but um
and reusable however the actual public
seed and secrecy that is sampled each
time he uses sprg
those two together have to have length m
to the y minus delta
okay and then finally what we need is
pseudorandomness
which is that when you look at the
public seed and the output of the pier
and the sprg
the that is super random okay and i'm
going to explain to you why that's true
and it's an extremely simple argument
and it is the only place
where the actual lpn over cp assumption
is used
okay and then looking ahead rachel will
tell us
why this object is sufficient to build
io she'll elaborate on
some of the things that gael just very
briefly sketched
towards the end of our talk and then
finally in part three
ayush will tell us how we can actually
achieve
both properties one and two which are
again really at the heart
of our of our construction achieving
this degree two efficiency and expansion
okay
but i get to the easy part i'm going to
show you pseudomonas
okay so let me tell you now
what the output of our sprg will be
okay and the output of the s versus you
will have two parts again this is going
to correspond to the public seed and the
the actual output and the part that
corresponds to the public seed
actually looks very much like what we
just saw in terms of an lpn
sample so as you can see on the slide
right now
the first part of the output will be a i
comma a i dot s
plus e i which is just like lpn but then
also plus x i okay where each xi is
uniformly sampled bits so there's zero
one
sampled at random okay and then
the second part of the output is this
kind of annoyingly correlated output it
is the output of
a prg on x1 up to xn
okay and so you know
we need to show that these are jointly
pseudorandom
kind of despite this annoying
correlation
the fact that xi is used can you hear me
i'm getting a notification that my
internet connection is unstable
i'm just quickly checking to see if
people are with me
we can hear you you can hear me yeah
yes okay all right okay excellent all
right very good
so um we want to show these jointly
surrounding despite this correlation
and um
[Music]
and uh and there is an insight here
actually that makes this very easy
which is that in earlier works in those
works that i cited before
there wasn't this lpn error there was
the entire error in the first component
was just xi so the first component used
to look like ai from the ai.s
xi and then the second component was prg
of x
but now we've added this bi that sort of
very simple insight that we had of just
adding one more error here
okay and therefore we kind of separated
the error into these two components
and now we're claiming that having done
so proving pseudorandomness
is now in fact straightforward and this
is where all of the earlier works were
kind of stuck
earlier we had to conjecture
pseudorandom and so this and that was
basically the assumption that was
underlying the earlier works
was that this is actually pseudorandom
when you don't have this
this ei part and now by adding this ei
part we're going to be able to prove it
to you in a very simple way
and actually i'm very tempted just
because i like the idea of having this
be interactive
uh it's very easy to see does anyone see
why is this true
how would you prove this how would you
prove that this is in fact pseudorandom
despite the sort of annoying fact that
we're using xi in both outputs
amit before we go to the quiz part um
what you see it here exactly
a is a private parameter right yes
a a is just a publicly uh random
public parameter which is just a random
l dimensional vector over z
let's see what's what's right
what is the seed here in this random
number generator
okay so the p um
good question you're talking about the
sprg right i want to postpone
answering that question but roughly
speaking the seed corresponds to
s the e i's and the x i's
so think of the think of the vector s
think of this e i and think of x i as
being the seed
ais are all part of the crs and so the
output are these two parts
but just to make sure so what's the gain
and what's the stretch here
oh you said it and i didn't good no no
the stretch will be because of the prg
so the prg is just a classic good old
prg
your favorite prg in fact we'll use the
prg and nc 0 something about gold right
but for this slide think of your
favorite prg
it can be any prg off the shelf so the
prg is expanding it it expands uh by a
polynomial factor it has m to the one
like n to the one plus epsilon outputs
and that's where our expansion will be
coming from looking ahead
but right now i'm agnostic to that let
prg be your favorite off-the-shelf
preview whichever one you like best
and all we need to claim is that for any
prg
these two outputs together are joined to
suit around i mean
so so in this case you're just a i mean
a a dot
s plus e i uh you're assuming that this
is indistinguishable from just a uniform
independent thing modulo p right
exactly yes so goals got it in in
instantly right so
it's extremely straightforward we start
on the slide you see here the output the
two outputs together
and just observe that a i comma ai
dot s plus e i this is exactly the lpn
sample so by the lpm assumption
this is indistinguishable from ai comma
ui right and then
the reduction here can just choose x i
itself
and there's just a trivial reduction so
the lpn assumption immediately applied
implies that this is indistinguishable
from a i comma u i plus x
i right and then of course if ui is
already uniform
if i add a random bit to it that's still
just uniform right this is identically
these just identical distributions you
can just think of this as ai comma ui
and then prg of x1 up to xn but now i've
removed the
the the dependency right this annoying
dependency this annoying
combination is now being removed and now
i can just apply
the pseudorandomness of the prg again no
matter what prg it is
and replace the output of the prg with
random so
in this extremely simple way we use the
lpn assumption
to break up this extremely annoying
dependency that was
really the porn in our side for the past
two years with
more than two years in all our previous
works we needed to
assume that a certain object was
pseudorandom and in this extremely
simple way by using lpn
uh as an assumption we were able to
break it up i want to
stress that i haven't told you about the
hardest part that you're going to have
to wait we're going to build up a
suspense
for that you have to wait until ayush
aisha's talk
so i haven't told you about the
efficiency aspect of this prg
um that is really an essential
part and the sparseness of the rei will
come up there again in a really critical
way
but when it comes to arguing
pseudo-randomness
it is completely straightforward
okay any questions about that i hope
everyone agrees this is very
straightforward
all right so um
so that and again that's my i promise
you this is the only place where we use
lpn in terms of the actual assumption
this is the only place in the entire
uh paper okay so what else do we assume
um as i already mentioned lwe is just
exactly the same as lpn except you have
gaussian small gaussian error ei instead
of sparse error
um that too we assume is is hard with
some exponential modules to noise ratio
and due to these you know beautiful
lines of work
you know girdle prize winning work um uh
regev and pikert and the kirstie at all
we know that this version of the elderly
assumption is true
if the shortest factor problem over
general lattices
is worst case hard to approximate to any
sub-exponential
factor again to any arbitrarily small
sub-exponential factor
so um that's the other assumption uh
that's the lw assumption that we make i
also want to point out that
just like with lpn there's also a search
to decision reduction for lwe
for example due to mid chance remote
this is well known
and as all of you know uh lw has turned
out to be incredibly versatile as an
assumption in cryptography
most famously for um philosophical
encryption
through the breakthrough work of
berkshire skinner
so we all know lw well we use it
and before i move on i do want to just
mention
that this little uh surroundings
analysis that i just gave
note that i didn't actually use anything
special about the lpn
distribution of error versus the lwe
distribution of error
this analysis of pseudorandomness would
have worked just as well
if these eis had been small instead of
sparse
so then why are we doing it why are we
using sparsity
it's because the sparsity turns out to
be crucial for computing
the sprg so this degree two computation
that we need
in the secret part of the secret seed
that is
another place where sparsity will come
back in an
absolutely critical way to do that yeah
while
i said that we will not be sticklers
with time let's try to
not not go too much over time so it may
be four is
i'm yeah i'm i'm almost done so
um so uh so so that's just a little
preview
and then we also assume the distance of
prgs that are
computable in nc 0 with polynomial
stretch
this has been extensively studied since
the work of goldrick
and um i think i i
mentioned maybe not everyone knows about
there's this beautiful work of
benny any and others which
shows that in fact this type of
pseudorandom assumption in nc 0
follows from one weiners conjecture so
if you're willing to assume some
exponential hardness of
inverting the gold rack one way function
then that also implies that uh there are
there are uh
prgs in nc zero with polynomial stretch
and then finally we also assume the sxgh
assumption over bilinear maps and this
is extensively studied in use
i'm not going to specify just because
the details of the actual assumption are
not important
and rachel will tell you about sort of
the actual aspect of the bilinear map
that we're using
so um and as yeah already mentioned as
i've already mentioned in order to get
to io
we do need to make all the assumptions
against of exponential time adversaries
if we only want to build functional
encryption then we only need the
assumptions against polynomial time
adversaries so we do also have a
consequence in our paper of building
functional encryption
which only requires polynomial
assumptions but if you want i o then you
have to make substantial time
assumptions
and that's it so what you're going to
see up ahead in
rachel's talk is how to use sprg
together with a bunch of other things
that have appeared in earlier works
to get to i o elaborating on what yael
said at the end of her talk
and then in part three ayush will tell
you how to actually build
uh the fish how to achieve the
efficiency property of the sprg this is
properties
one and two the degree two property and
the expansion property
uh assuming prg's in nc zero and and the
sparseness of the error from lpn
and with that i'll conclude
thank you thank you this is a
very exciting and uh yes people can
ask questions uh if you're breaking off
you can go
also to the govern space if you would
like to the the
i can put the link
here in the chat
if it lets me yes and so
but people can ask questions and then
yes the next talk will
be at 11 minutes from now at um
1 30 eastern 10 30 pacific or probably
unless you're in india it's a 30 uh
when the minute clock shows 30 wherever
you are
all right any questions
so if there are no more questions let's
take the 10 minute break so people can
stretch and meet up again in
10 minutes